De las cinco mayores economías del mundo,
una en concreto es fundamentalmente una potencia
marítima. Sí, obviamente hablamos de Japón.
La peculiaridad de Japón -además de que se
trata de un archipiélago- es que sus mares
territoriales y sus aguas interiores suman más
superficie que la que tiene en tierra firme:
Hablamos de unos 430.000 kilómetros
cuadrados versus algo menos de 380.000.
Y, por supuesto, a ello tendríamos que sumarle
la zona económica exclusiva. Esto es, aquellas
aguas que no forman parte estrictamente
de un país pero sobre las que este tiene
derechos especiales a la hora de explotar sus
recursos. Una zona que según la convención de
Naciones Unidas sobre el derecho del mar se
extiende 200 millas náuticas desde la costa.
En definitiva, que Japón tiene mucho,
muchísimo más mar que tierra que defender.
Y eso no es todo. Al margen de la mera
geografía, si nos fijamos en dónde está
concentrada la población japonesa veremos
que aproximadamente la mitad de sus 126
millones de habitantes viven próximos a
sus 35.000 kilómetros de línea de costa.
Todo esto hace de Japón un país esencialmente
echado al mar. Un país que tanto para su
economía como para su propia defensa
mira sobre todo a las aguas marinas.
Es decir, que no solo hablamos ni
mucho de una cuestión geográfica,
sino sobre todo de una económica y militar.
(Más del 99% del comercio internacional
de Japón se lleva a cabo por barco. Esto
incluye el 80% de toda la energía
y el 99% del petróleo que consumen.
En otras palabras, sin unos mares seguros o
que estén bajo su control o el de sus aliados,
toooda la economía nipona estaría expuesta
a una enorme vulnerabilidad. Y, ojo,
porque tal y como veremos esta es la
idea determina en gran medida todos
los planes de seguridad del país del
sol naciente. Aquí el mar vale doble.)
Y claro, pensadlo un momento. Ya os
hemos contado, aquí en VisualPolitik,
cómo China está construyendo la mayor
flota naval del mundo por número de buques.
Y también os hemos contado cómo
las ambiciones de Pekín pasan,
precisamente, por controlar los mares
que les rodean. Y evidentemente eso es
algo que tiene muchas implicaciones para sus
países vecinos…Entre ellos el propio Japón.
(3 noviembre 2022: La Armada de China marca
un ritmo récord de incursiones
en el mar territorial de Japón
Los buques de la Armada del
Ejército Popular de Liberación
han entrado en aguas territoriales
japonesas ocho veces desde 2004,
y cinco de ellas han ocurrido desde
octubre de 2021. - The Diplomat)
Con semejante percal no nos
puede extrañar por qué en
Japón esto está generando cada vez más inquietud.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Es precisamente por eso
por lo que se están poniendo las pilas.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os vamos a
contar cómo ahora Japón parece
decidido a construir una fuerte
defensa aeronaval para proteger sus costas
y sus interés económicos y territoriales.
Y por supuesto también os contaremos
cuáles son sus puntos más débiles.
¿Estaremos acaso ante el nuevo
despertar militar del país
del sol naciente? ¿Hasta qué punto
Japón, una gran potencia económica,
puede convertirse también en toda una potencia
militar y un actor clave en Asia-Pacífico? ¿Por
qué la fuerza naval puede ser fundamental a
la hora de garantizar la seguridad de Japón?
Y ojo que no hablamos solo de China.
Así que… Arranquemos.
T1 (¡ASEGURAD LAS LÍNEAS!)
Fijaos por un momento en este mapa.
Lo que estáis viendo son las principales
líneas de comunicación marítimas,
las conocidas como SLOC por sus siglas en inglés.
Hablamos de rutas de miles de millas náuticas por
las que pasan no solo el grueso de las
exportaciones e importaciones de Japón,
sino también de algunas de las mayores
economías del mundo, como China o Corea del Sur.
Y ojo porque cuando hablamos de
exportaciones e importaciones no
solo nos referimos a bienes de consumo sino
también, y quizás todavía más importante,
a equipos industriales y suministros energéticos.
(Para que os hagáis una idea, aproximadamente
la mitad de todo el gas natural licuado que
importa Japón pasa por alguno de los
hot spots, de los puntos calientes,
que tienen las SLOC que hemos visto en el
mapa. Especialmente importantes son las zonas
del estrecho de Ormuz, del estrecho
de Malaca y del estrecho de Taiwán.
Y ojo porque hablamos de volúmenes enormes. Con
algo más de 74 millones de toneladas al año,
Japón es, por ejemplo, el segundo mayor
importador de LNG del mundo justo por
detrás de China, que se situó en
lo más alto del podio en 2021.)
Y eso si hablamos del gas. Porque si hablamos
del petróleo entonces la importancia de estos
hot spots marinos es mucho mayor. El 90
por ciento, sí, sí el 90 por ciento de
todo el petróleo que importa Japón procede
de Oriente Medio. Así que tiene que cruzar
todos esos puntos calientes donde puede
pasar de todo y, creedme, nada bueno.
Por ejemplo el estrecho de Ormuz, que separa
Emiratos Árabes Unidos y Omán de Irán,
tiene en algunos puntos menos
de 34 kilómetros de ancho.
Y esto se vuelve todavía más importante
cuando tenemos en cuenta el hecho de que
hablamos de una zona especialmente
tensa por las amenazas e incluso
ataques y asaltos que recurrentemente
Irán comete contra buques mercantes.
(13 de junio de 2019: Un buque japonés
es atacado cerca del Estrecho de Ormuz;
Estados Unidos culpa a Irán - Kyodo News)
(4 de enero de 2021: Un tanquero surcoreano
es incautado por Irán en el
Estrecho de Ormuz - Arab News)
Estos titulares son tan solo dos ejemplos,
pero la lista es larga, muy larga.
Y de hecho este tipo tensión lejos de
disminuir parece que pueden ir a más.
Así que, como os podéis imaginar, las
operaciones militares de los países más
interesados en asegurar sus líneas de
suministro se están volviendo bastante
frecuentes en estas zonas, especialmente
en lo que respecta a la escolta de barcos.
(Un buque de guerra japonés parte
hacia el Golfo para patrullar las
rutas de suministro de petróleo - Reuters)
(“Miles de barcos japoneses navegan esas
aguas [del Golfo] cada año, incluyendo
buques que transportan el 90% de nuestro
petróleo. Es la línea de vida de Japón.” -
Antiguo Primer Ministro japonés Shinzo Abe,
en la base naval de Yokosuka cerca de Tokyo.)
El problema amigos es que si pensáis
que después de pasar el estrecho de
Ormuz ya todo es pan comido… Siento
decepcionaros pero estáis muy equivocados.
Después de conseguir cruzar sanos y salvos esta
zona, los buques llenos de Gas Natural Licuado,
petróleo o mercancías que van hacia Japón y Corea
tienen que enfrentarse a una segunda zona
caliente: los mares del Sudeste Asiático.
Unos mares donde el riesgo es doble:
hablamos de China y también de los piratas.
Hace poco en nuestro canal hermano
VisualEconomik -si no lo conoces,
algo mal estás haciendo en tu vida-
os hablamos sobre la pirateria,
y especialmente sobre los piratas de Somalia.
Si aún no lo habéis visto, pero os interesa
el mundo de la economía no olvidéis echarle
un vistazo. El enlace, abajo como siempre.
El caso es que si os preguntara cuál es la
zona del planeta que más sufre la pirateria
y el secuestro de barcos, seguramente
muchos me responderíais que sin duda se
trata de la Zona del Cuerno de África,
en el entorno precisamente de Somalia,
¿Verdad? [Vamos, seguro que todos tenemos en mente
la película del Capitán Phillips, de Tom Hanks]
Pues… Lo siento, pero no, error, gran error. Es
cierto que en la zona del Cuerno de África estuvo
la cuna de la piratería moderna. Sin embargo,
la región con más piratas y que concentra
cerca del 60% de todos los casos actualmente se
sitúa en el Sudeste Asiático. ¿Cómo te quedas?
Especialmente hablamos de las áreas
de los estrechos de Malaca y de Sunda,
y de las zonas próximas a las
costas de Vietnam, de Camboya,
de Indonesia y de Malasia. Estos
son los puntos más calientes. Pero
es que incluso al norte de Taiwán
se han llegado a registrar ataques.
Y sí, si le echáis un vistazo de nuevo al mapa de
las SLOC que os pusimos antes veréis que por ahí
también pasan las principales rutas de importación
y exportación de Japón y Corea del Sur.
(Obviamente esto obliga a desplegar en
la zona un nivel extra de seguridad,
lo que se suele lograr gracias a
la colaboración internacional de
los países interesados y de los
países soberanos de las aguas.
¿El problema? Pues que muchos de estos países del
Sudeste Asiático todavía no tienen Armadas fuertes
ni recursos suficientes con los que asegurar
sus mares, así que la gran responsabilidad
recae en los propios países interesados
en proteger el tráfico marítimo. Lo que
incluye a China y a Estados Unidos. Pero para
países como Japón eso puede no ser suficiente.)
A Tokio no le hace ninguna pero que ninguna
gracia que la seguridad de sus suministros
pase por la buena voluntad de Xi Jinping.
Y es por ese motivo que poco a poco este
país ha tratado de ir desarrollando una
ambiciosa política de defensa naval.
(En 1981 el Primer Ministro Zenko Suzuki implantó
la llamada Política de Defensa de
Rutas Marítimas de 1.000 millas.
Básicamente esta política consiste en
que los buques militares japoneses se
reservan el derecho a intervenir para
proteger sus intereses comerciales en
un área de hasta 1.000 millas náuticas
de distancia del territorio japonés.
Esto es lo que explica en parte por qué
Japón ha puesto tanto empeño en hacer
reclamaciones territoriales de islas lejanas,
algunas a priori aparentemente absurdas.
Pues bien, con ello lo que buscan es
alejar lo más posible esa línea de
defensa marítima al mismo tiempo que
intentan legitimarla de algún modo.)
Y eso queridos amigos, amigas, es
lo que explica noticias como esta:
(3 Febrero 2016: Japón gastará millones
en diminutas islas 1.000 millas
al sur de Tokyo - The Guardian)
El problema es que debido a sus históricas
reticencias a la hora de construir unas fuerzas
armadas grandes, Japón no tiene capacidades
suficientes como para hacer valer esa política.
Así que, en la práctica, China ha seguido
ganando terreno durante todos estos años.
Para colmo, una de las excusas de China para
expandirse por el Mar de la China Meridional y
sus alrededores es precisamente el agresivo
planteamiento de defensa marítima de Japón,
que hace que las zonas de interés
de uno y otro país se solapen.
El resultado es que a medida que China
ha ido modernizando sus fuerzas armadas
y construyendo la mayor armada del planeta,
la inquietud y la tensión de Tokio ha ido
creciendo más y más. Y especialmente tras
la cada vez mayor ambición de Xi Jingpin.
En este sentido la toma de Hong Kong
y la constante hostilidad sobre Taiwán
han sido auténticos puntos de inflexión
para el gobierno japonés. Un gobierno
que empieza a tener auténtico pavor
de terminar siendo en la práctica
un país satélite o al menos un país
sometido a los designios de Pekín.
Y justo aquí llegamos a la tercera clave
que explica por qué Japón tiene entre ceja
y ceja volver a convertirse
en una superpotencia naval.
Y es que, veréis. El Estrecho
de Taiwán es probablemente la
zona militarmente más tensa de los
mares de Asia Or iental. Hablamos
de un estrecho que es particularmente
relevante para Japón por dos motivos.
El primero es que Taiwán es
un país que, literalmente,
está bajo la protección implícita de Japón.
Ya os lo contamos en un pasado vídeo,
los intereses económicos y estratégicos de Japón
en Taiwán son enormes, así que su estabilidad
es clave no sólo en términos políticos sino
también para las propias empresas japonesas.
El segundo motivo tiene que
ver con lo mismo que venimos
insistiendo en este vídeo. La larga ruta
de suministros y mercancías entre Japón,
Europa y Oriente Medio también
pasa por el entorno de Taiwán.
En otras palabras, virtualmente toda
la economía japonesa depende de la
estabilidad de una serie de zonas que se
están convirtiendo en todo un polvorín de
tensiones y amenazas. Y para colmo hoy por hoy
esa estabilidad depende cada vez más de China.
En otras palabras, que la mayor amenaza para
Japón no es ni mucho menos que un buen día
China quisiera desatar una guerra o invadir
este país. No, la mayor amenaza tiene mucho
que ver con la cada vez mayor capacidad de Pekín
para estrangular, presionar y coaccionar a Japón.
Así que con todo esto en cuenta
la pregunta es muy clara:
¿Qué opciones tienen los japoneses
para proteger su economía,
sus líneas de suministro y la
propia integridad del país?
Pues por un lado incrementar
y profundizar sus alianzas
internacionales. Qué es precisamente lo
que está haciendo con Estados Unidos,
con Reino Unido, con la India, con
Australia, e incluso con Corea del Sur.
(6 de septiembre de 2022: Corea del Sur y
Japón establecieron las primeras conversaciones
militares de alto nivel en 6 años. Asia Nikkei)
(8 de septiembre de 2022: India y Japón
realizarán más ejercicios militares para
estrechar lazos. Al Jazeera)
(23 de Octubre de 2022:
Japón y Australia refuerzan su pacto
de seguridad frente a la amenaza china)
(5 de noviembre de 2022:
Japón firma un pacto militar con el
Reino Unido ante la amenaza china. FT)
Pero ahí no termina todo. Por otro lado,
la opción es reconstruir su armada y volver
convertirse en una gran potencia marítima
Con el auge de China en la región, ya no les queda
otra si no quieren terminar convirtiéndose en un
país vasallo. ¿Y sabéis qué? En Japón lo saben.
(El nuevo Libro Blanco de Defensa de Japón de
2022 exige un impulso militar masivo
para contrarrestar a China - Reuters)
Exacto, Japón quiere rearmarse a
toda velocidad y quiere hacerlo
sobre todo apostando por el mar
y por la tecnología balística.
Dicho esto, ¿queréis saber más
detalles sobre los planes de
Japón para volver a convertirse
en toda una potencia militar?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (EL REGRESO DEL SOL NACIENTE)
Japón está de vuelta en el campo militar.
Eso es algo que ya no se puede negar.
Y tal y como os estamos contando,
de todo el gasto que se va llevar a cabo
para reforzar las capacidades militares,
la conocida como Fuerza Marítima de Autodefensa
y la Fuerza Aérea se van a llevar la mayor parte.
Es decir, el objetivo será crear
una nueva fuerza aeronaval capaz
de defender los intereses de Japón en toda
la región, siendo mucho menos dependientes
de Estados Unidos y siendo incluso capaces
de rivalizar con China. Ese es el objetivo.
Ahora bien, ¿de qué estamos hablando exactamente?
(Pues veréis, Japón tiene la intención
de gastar algo más de 300 mil millones
de dólares durante los próximos
cinco años en sus fuerzas armadas.
De este modo pretenden gastar al
menos el 2% del PIB en defensa
cuando hasta ahora a duras penas llegaban al 1%.
Con este plan, los nipones se convertirán
en el tercer país de todo el mundo con
mayor presupuesto militar tan sólo
por detrás de Estados Unidos y China)
Todo un giro a décadas de política militar.
De momento el gobierno japonés no ha presentado
un plan integral claro que nos diga cuáles
serán todas sus prioridades. Sin embargo ya se
están comenzando a anunciar algunos proyectos.
Por ejemplo, tenemos el caso de dos destructores
con capacidades de defensa contra misiles
balísticos en los que Japón ha invertido
unos 7.100 millones de dólares.
]Eso.. Eso son muchos yukichis]
Y no sé, así dicho puede parecer poca cosa,
dos barcos más. Sin embargo
la realidad es muy diferente.
(Cuando se entreguen serán los destructores
más grandes de Japón y dos de los más grandes
de todas las aguas de Asia. Hablamos de 20.000
toneladas de peso cada uno y 210 metros de largo.
Estos buques que se espera que sean entregados
en torno al año 2027 estarán además equipados
con el más avanzado sistema de combate
Aegis con misiles interceptores SM-3,
que a día de hoy son la creme
de la creme en su clase.)
Y por supuesto esta no es la única novedad.
(Japón pone en servicio la primera nueva
fragata multipropósito de clase Mogami
El Kumano es el primero de los 22
buques planificados de la clase,
que incluirá capacidades nunca antes vistas
en una fragata japonesa. - The Diplomat)
De hecho, son este nuevo grupo de
fragatas las que Japón utilizará en
misiones de vigilancia marítima dentro
y fuera de Japón, incluido en la zona
del Mar de la China Meridional donde os
hemos contado que hay tantos problemas.
Pero todavía podemos encontrar más novedades.
(Por ejemplo, Japón anunció en marzo de 2022
que al igual que hizo con el primer buque
iniciará los trabajos para convertir
el segundo destructor multipropósito
de la clase Izumo en un portaaviones. De
esta forma los dos barcos de esta clase
se convertirán en los primeros portaaviones
con bandera japonesa desde la época imperial
Estos portaaviones operarán además
42 cazas de quinta generación F-35B
con despegue vertical. Se usarán
para disuadir a China de realizar
incursiones aéreas tanto en Japón
como en los cielos de sus aliados.
Además, sumados a los F-35A que
Japón ya tiene o que están pedidos,
el país operará la friolera de 147
de estos aparatos de aquí a unos
pocos años. Será la segunda mayor flota de
F-35 tan sólo por detrás de Estados Unidos)
Como os podéis imaginar, todo esto junto a
los drones Global Hawk estadounidenses y dos
nuevos aviones cisterna para repostaje
Boeing KC-46A le va a proporcionar a
los nipones una capacidad de defensa
aeronaval muy pero que muy importante.
Y eso no es todo. Recientemente
ha saltado esta noticia:
N12 (9 de diciembre de 2022: Japón,
Gran Bretaña e Italia planean un avión
de combate de sexta generación
para rivalizar con los aviones
de guerra más avanzados del mundo. CNN)
Japón, Reino Unido e Italia desarrollarán
conjuntamente y con el respaldo de Estados Unidos
un avión de combate de última generación para
completar sus flotas de F-35 y superar ampliamente
las capacidades militares de China y de Rusia.
Ese es el objetivo que estos tres países han
hecho público. Un acuerdo al que
pronto podrían sumarse más países.
Y es que, de hecho, los japoneses quieren
llevar su rearme tan lejos que incluso se
plantean desarrollar un misil hipersónico -sí, sí,
un misil hipersónico- que entraría
en servicio para el año 2030.
(3 Noviembre 2022: Japón valora desplegar un misil
hipersónico para 2030 para impulsar la disuasión)
Impresionante, ¿no os parece? ¡Estamos hablando
de Japón! Los que nos seguís desde hace tiempo ya
sabéis que Japón desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial
siempre ha sido reacio a todo el tema militar.
Y no solo por el espíritu pacífico
que recoge su Constitución,
sino también por una especie de convicción social.
Pero ya se ha terminado. Las reglas del juego
han cambiado con el auge militar de China,
con una Corea del Norte que no deja
de provocar con misiles cada vez
más avanzados y con una Rusia que
se dedica a invadir otros países.
Y no olvidéis, como detalle, que Japón
y Rusia hacen prácticamente frontera y
que tienen una disputa territorial
abierta sobre las islas Kuriles.
(Japón acaba de aprobar su nueva
estrategia de defensa, la cual incluye,
entre otras cosas, la capacidad de realizar
contraataques contra bases militares en el
extranjero. Además Kishida no descarta
ir más allá en el futuro e incluir la
posibilidad de realizar ataques preventivos.
(16 diciembre 2022: Japón aprueba la capacidad
de atacar bases enemigas en un importante
cambio de política de defensa - Kyodo News)
Algo difícilmente encajable en su marco
legal sin una reforma de la Constitución.
Una reforma que cada vez tiene más
partidarios en la política japonesa.
En fin, así es cómo están las cosas. La pregunta
ahora es para ti: ¿Crees que Japón terminará
convirtiéndose en toda una potencia aeronaval
capaz de rivalizar tú a tú con la mismísima
China? ¿Puede Japón convertirse en la mano
derecha de los Estados Unidos en la región?
Déjanos tus opiniones aquí abajo en
los comentarios. Y si te ha gustado
este vídeo no te olvides de darle
いいね [ii ne] y suscribirte a nuestro
canal. Y recuerda que también puedes
apoyarnos activamente sumándose a
nuestra comunidad en Patreon. Os dejamos
el enlace aquí abajo, en la descripción.
Como siempre, どうもありがとう [doomo
arigato] por estar ahí. Un
saludo y またね
[Mata ne]